very good morning to you we start the
show with some breaking news this
morning the latest retail sales figures
show a rise of 0.3
i will bring you more details on that a
little bit later this morning
but first to our top story and a day
after strikes cut off swathes of the
country's rail network and a day before
that happens again london transport
workers are walking out today in a
dispute over pay and pensions
tube and overground services are either
cancelled or barely running and a
coinciding bus strike is disrupting
dozens of routes in the capital
well across the country rail commuters
are dealing with delays from the
knock-on effects of yesterday's national
strikes
in london more than 10 000 london
underground and overground workers are
amongst those striking today
leaving lines running sparsely or in
some cases not at all
the boss strike today and tomorrow will
cancel 57 routes mainly through west and
southwest london as well as surrey
and saturday we'll see a repeat of
thursday's uk wide rail strikes with
about forty thousand workers taking part
well i'm joined now by the transport
secretary grant shaps uh grant chapter
very good morning to you uh good to have
you on the programme let's talk about
strike zen shall we because once again
uh we're suffering from them here in
london on the underground and bus
services we've got rail strikes across
the country again tomorrow why is this
not been resolved
i think essentially now because the
union bosses won't put the uh settlement
deals to their members so we've had a
situation where uh eight percent over
two years has been offered it's
different depending on which piece of
the rail we're talking about here but
broadly speaking
and uh the uh bosses for example the
boss of the rmt uh simply make the
decision without going out to their
membership to ask them whether they
would like to uh settle this and and get
back to work where it has gone to the
members that was in a smaller union
called the tssa
uh the members overwhelmingly voted for
that deal uh over 70 percent so it's
quite clear that the union bosses are
trying to prevent the workers from
actually being we put the offer have the
offer put in front of them
well yeah you say it's all down to the
union bosses and you've really come out
fighting on this haven't you as far as
the unions are concerned
you published a 16-point plan as well
about taking on the unions but don't
most people just want a resolution they
want to see you talking to the to the
unions yourself they want a more
consideratory tone have you got this
wrong
yeah so the it's for the employers and
the unions to discuss this obviously
because they're the only two who can
settle it um and indeed they've been in
discussion and uh i think what is a very
reasonable pay offer has been made
remember the average rail worker the
medium is uh 44 000 pounds so that's the
average salary on a train driver and the
train drivers are also house on strike
with a separate union their average is
nearly 60 000 pounds
so we're you know i'm all in favor of
well-paid uh rail workers uh who
received a huge amount of support from
your viewers the taxpayers during the
virus um june coronavirus to the tune of
16 billion pounds or 600 pounds for
every household watching your program so
the public has supported the railway and
the railway workers it's time for the
union bosses to get out the way and put
the deals on the table to their members
so we can have this thing settled and
the point about my 16-point plan which
is really to look at the union
legislation and see if it's in the right
place is really to hand that power uh
back to the to the rail workers uh or
workers across the whole economy
actually not just in rail rather than
have it sit with some of these union
bosses who you know in some cases
including the rmt boss say they hanker
for the days of union baron power from
the 1970s we don't need that kind of
industrial relations we just need to
have this thing settled
well we do need to have this thing
settled and the union bosses would say
that the offer that's on the table falls
way below inflation and when a lot of
people sympathize with that there are a
lot of people around the country who are
facing inflation outstripping their own
wages and isn't it the case that a lot
of people will have sympathy with those
railway workers when they're
they're not tempted to take an offer
that's below inflation
i think we're all concerned that you
know
everyone would have sympathy within the
inflation argument and you know let's
remember it's the supply chain
recovering after coronavirus it's putin
going to war uh in ukraine that's caused
this global uh inflation spike um but
the offer on the table is pretty decent
for as i say the average train worker on
44 000 the average driver on 60 000
pounds a government's got to sort of
balance that with you know nurses who
are paid 31 000 or care workers 21 000
you know i think it's important that we
balance that across the economy of
course everyone would love for it to be
more in fact one of the good things for
um the railways is some of the reforms
required some of the modernizations are
so out of date for example paper
timesheets being used still on the
maintenance side in some cases
maintenance teams not allowed to be sent
from for example houston to kings cross
because the rmt claims those that five
minute walk puts them in two different
regions and you can't therefore use the
maintenance teams and so many other
examples means that there are actually a
lot of modernizations that can help fund
some of these pay increases but as i say
the big block is that these union bosses
refuse to allow the offer on the table
to be put to their members it's one of
the reasons in my 16-point plan to
tackle the unions that i'm saying that
in future it should be the case that
union members have to put proper offers
to their membership rather than blocking
them at uh at union executives okay or
reunion baron level
so you're saying that the unions are
blocking progress that the mick lynch
the rmt says that you're the obstacle to
progress and he says the government's
bailing out companies to enable them to
continue working during strikes he's
also suggesting the government's backing
compulsory redundancies so are you
well the deal on the table um actually
for the rmt particularly on the network
rail side as i say it's slightly
complicated here because there are
several different negotiations in play
across the railway but the deal that's
on the table actually means largely no
compulsory redundancies at all uh again
if you're not prepared to put that deal
to your membership we'll never know
whether the members would accept it what
i do know and i can say for sure is if
we can't get this settled uh in the way
that we're proposing which is please put
the deal to your membership then we will
have to move to what's called a section
188 this is a process of
actually requiring these changes to go
into place so it becomes mandated
and that is the direction this is moving
in now so these reforms these
modernizations some of which update
rules that go back to the 50s 60s and
70s one which is the the inability for
us to run a service properly on a sunday
without people volunteering so we can't
contractually put this in place goes
back 100 years over 100 years if we
can't get those modernizations in place
we will have to impose those
modernizations but we'd much rather do
it through these these offers actually
being put to their members
steve white uh is the managing director
of southeastern railway he he's
frustrated he's tweeted actually saying
does any railway colleague or customer
really want this to last for months it's
time for a ceasefire our people deserve
a pay rise and job security so he's
calling there for a pay rise he says our
industries exist to serve our customers
and community more talks are needed then
some more and then some more you should
be around the table shouldn't you
sorting this out now
well the people who have to be around
the table are the employers and uh the
workers representatives in this case the
the unions um they're the only people
who can settle the strike uh of course
government sets the mandate overall uh
because we have the further wider
responsibility for not just how much
real workers are paid but how much uh
care workers are paid how much staff in
the nhs doctors and nurses and police
and so many other public services so of
course we have to set an overall
framework the treasury has has done that
in a way as i say um rail is fortunate
there is so much modernization required
for work practices which have no place
in the 21st century uh at all i'll give
you a good example of this is um there
are the same number of ticket offers
more or less than there were when
virtually all the tickets were sold at
ticket offices we want to get people out
from behind the glass and onto the
stations helping helping customers sorry
to interrupt you but you're saying this
has got nothing to do with the
government there's nothing you can do
there's nothing you can do to move this
on
and that's not what i'm saying i'm
saying the government has to set the
overall mandate the framework but the
technical discussions have to take place
between the employers and the unions and
they have been and that's why we've got
offers of eight percent over two years
on the table with as i said it varies
depending on which part of the
which which union and which part of the
railway we're talking about but no
compulsory redundancies for example with
the network rail maintenance side uh and
much more
if the unions won't put the offer to
their members i'm afraid we will have to
impose some of these solutions and
that's where we're moving to now
okay talking about solutions labour has
called for the government to restore
avanti west coast services after they've
announced a reduced service we've got um
andy burnham the mayor of manchester
talking to us a little bit later on so
tell us what what you're doing about
this what what action are you going to
take
well
it's
a bit
pot kettle black because
the the problem on of anti-west coast
which is to do with um the azleth union
uh calling unofficial uh action and they
voted for uh action shorts and strikes
so we know that is the case has meant
that they withdrawn
voluntary day working it actually
exemplifies everything that's wrong
about the way that the railway is being
run that rather than contractually
running our railway we have volunteer
days to do it and we had a 90 drop
three days after the union voted to
withdraw uh
to do everything short of striking so we
know it must be connected um to that
ballot uh which meant that avanti west
coast could no longer run a reliable
service so when you have andy burnham on
i hope you're going to ask him since he
takes money from the unions when he's
going to tell his friends in the unions
um to get this sorted out and stop
playing games with people's lives the
only reason they're not running a
service is because of those unions and
they are demonstrating why the railway
is so desperately need of reform and as
i say we will bring in that reform my
16-point plan which i have no doubt the
the new government the new
administration will be adopting will in
fact bring this reform uh if the unions
aren't going to settle at any other time
is this really about strikes isn't this
about train companies just not having
the drivers that they need and
he would say to you no doubt are you
going to withdraw the franchise if they
don't come up with some solution to this
but the solution's been there all along
right so ordinary enough drivers though
to cover their shifts
in a second ordinarily and this is
because we have this extraordinary
situation on our railways where what's
called rest day working or overtime
is what's used in many cases to run
services so to give you an example on
northern clearly here on on the west
coast quite a lot of the service has to
be filled by people simply volunteering
to work those days any normal contract
any normal contract would say that
you're contractually required to work on
certain days up to a certain number of
hours of course we don't have that on
large parts of our railway which is
crazy and it's one of the things that
we're trying to change to modernize our
railway just because in 1919
sundays were protected um as a rest day
where no one ever worked there's no
longer fit with the 21st century where
actually particularly post coronavirus
more people are traveling for leisure so
more people are traveling on sundays
than any other day and yet we're stuck
with these contracts which simply don't
reflect the reality of today so i hope
when you're speaking to any of the uh
unions or any of the labour party andy
burnham included who take money from
these unions who are messing up our
railway and messing with people's lives
stopping people from getting to work
during the week many of whom will be the
hardest people in britain i hope you'll
be saying to them that rather than be
conflicted and talk speak up for the
unions they'll speak up for the
traveling public which is what we're
doing which is why we're requiring these
reforms which deserve support
okay as transport secretary i also want
to ask you about pno because uh as you
will know they announced sudden
redundancies back in march uh but its
owner has reported a bumper profit so
what's your reaction
well look as far as pno are concerned i
i i've been absolutely crystal clear i
think their boss the ceo
needs to resign he's still under
investigation uh which is uh absolutely
right for the way that he behaved uh and
we've changed the law
with regard to
some of the kind of detail of what
happened there and we brought forward a
nine-point plan to make sure that no
ferry company could do this again
including ensuring legislating to make
sure that they have to pay the minimum
wage when they are
frequently in british waters so p are
going to have to overturn what they've
done here they will have no choice in
law very shortly they should recognize
that and make that change now
you're backing rishi sunak in the
conservative leadership race is it time
for him to hand in the towel he's more
than 30 points behind in the polls and
the government has urgent business it
needs to address with the cost of living
crisis we're told we have to wait for a
new prime minister for action to be
taken
i mean we'll know who the new prime
minister is in a little over two weeks i
i don't think uh it would be right for
uh either side to uh not allow a formal
vote to go ahead and if there's one
thing we've learned from the last few
years as uh you know i think of the 2015
election i was passing chairman at the
time everyone said we couldn't win the
uh the election i think 2016 brexit uh
poll where everyone was pretty sure the
country was about to vote for remain i
think it'd be a very good idea to wait
for those who are voting in this contest
to complete the vote so it's only just
over a fortnight's time and we'll know
the the answer to that um and uh you
know in the meantime many of us are
working very hard to to make sure that
um you know services are available this
summer is what i've been doing i haven't
been away this summer i've been looking
after the transport system to make sure
that people can get away on holiday for
example
okay well grant chaps uh we appreciate
your time this morning thanks very much
indeed for joining us here on sky news
time now to get more on today's strikes
uh skies correspondent matthew thompson
is at vauxhall station for us in south
london right now so so matthew how's it
looking there right now
lots of frustrated faces as you can
probably imagine from bleary-eyed
morning commuters this morning as london
underground workers and overground
workers from the rmt union are joining
colleagues bus drivers from the united
union in a series of walkouts that set
to bring much of public transport in the
capital to a halt today
around 10 000 london underground workers
400 london overground workers joining
the strikes commuters are being urged to
work from home if possible and the
disruption is set to last until about
eight o'clock tomorrow morning and it
comes really sandwiched in between two
other days of strikes yesterday of
course we saw widespread strikes one in
five uh train services were cancelled
tomorrow yet another day of strikes
planned and well what's it all about you
heard some of the arguments rehearsed by
the transport secretary there the unions
won't pay settlements that better
reflect the cost of living crisis the
soaring inflation levels which have hit
40-year highs they also want guarantees
uh on job security and things like that
amidst cuts that the government are
proposing the government it's determined
not to buy to those demands as you heard
from the transport secretary there but
another one of the arguments we've heard
from the prime minister from the bank of
england is that they're determined to
avoid something called a wage price
spiral which is basically a term
economists use for an idea that when
inflation rises and demands for wages
follow them you get this vicious circle
where wages start chasing prices and
inflation gets even worse although other
economists and certainly the unions have
said that is a myth certainly the rmt's
mick lynch has said last night that
these strikes will go on as long as it
takes meaning that the summer of
discontent could well become an autumn
and even a winter too
thanks very much indeed for that
we'll of course be covering it every
step of the way uh in the meantime let's
take a look at what's on this morning's
front pages shall we and the daily mail
says that 43 000 students have been left
scrambling for a place at university
after a-level results created what it
describes as a clearing frenzy
the eye reports on a warning from the
office for budget responsibility to tory
leadership front-runner liz truss about
her spending promises
analyst trust also makes the front of
the express with a pledge about new laws
to crack down on strike action
the guardian reports that bonuses for
water company bosses were up at 20
percent last year even though they
failed to meet targets on sewage
pollution
now some breaking news in the last hour
or so a drought has been declared in
parts of wales this morning after the
driest five-month period in 40 years
natural resources wales said that the
threshold to trigger drought status in
southwest wales has now been met the
areas affected include north carolinian
tyvee pembrokeshire camarvon swansea
clenettely neath port talbot and
bridgend
well a hose pipe ban has also come into
effect in pembrokeshire and parts of
kamathen share due to the strain on
public water supplies it comes after
weeks of hot dry weather which has also
led to drought being declared and hosted
by bands coming into force in areas of
england
and experts are warning that any rain
currently forecast is expected to be
short and unlikely to change the
situation
well with parts of the world
experiencing extreme weather conditions
let's take a look shall we at the impact
of climate change on the planet and show
you our data dashboard and on the right
hand side of the screen there you can
see how the uk's power is currently
being produced 45 coming from gas at the
moment for example
top left you can see how much warmer the
earth is now than back in 1880 around
the time the industrial revolution that
is and when records began
1.25 degrees and finally at the bottom
left is the total amount of co2
emissions globally
that have been pushed out that's in
millions of tons and as you can see that
number going up all the time
now do stay with us here on sky news
breakfast i'll come here on the show
with london's transport largely at a
halt from strike action we'll ask a tfl
manager
where next for talks with union late
leaders
and we'll also check in on the tory
leadership race with liz trust backing
mp jake berry
and then at on state i'll be joined by
the mayor of london city khan and i'll
be asking him where he stands on the
demands of striking transport workers
but right now let's go back to that
breaking news we brought you the
beginning of the show that retail sales
rose slightly last month by 0.3 percent
but more broadly over the three months
of july sales were down by 1.2 percent
now this comes alongside new data this
morning showing that consumer confidence
has hit an all-time low faced with
soaring prices and a forecast of a
recession this guy's adele robinson
joins me now from reading so adele all
eyes on how much spending power people
feel that they have and the news isn't
great this morning
no it's not great there was some
surprise though because economists had
predicted um a dip similar to june
for retail sales in june as you said
retail sales went down by 0.2 of a
percent uh but in july they rose by 0.3
of a percent uh however as the office
for national statistics has said the
overall downward trend for retail sales
is continuing if you look a little bit
more into the data as well there are
some explanations for
that rise surprising rise in retail
sales uh the non-store retailing which
basically means online
buying that rose by 4.8 but it's
believed that was driven by uh
promotions that had boosted sales uh
when you look at um clothing and
household sales they were actually down
which shows that people are still
cutting back on what they're spending
amid concerns over affordability and the
cost of living as well so it does
reflect overall an economy that's still
grappling with increasing or and record
food prices as well as fuel prices over
those june and july months as well but
then coupled with the consumer
confidence index which you've just
mentioned there that showed record lows
in in how people are feeling uh and
that's um calculated in five different
ways five different measures and each of
those they look at things like personal
finance and also looking at people's
attitudes to and their thoughts on the
economy over the last year and then
looking ahead and each of those areas
were down as well
in fact
that overall the consumer confidence
index fell by three points in august
which was the lowest since 1974
when it began uh it fell originally back
in may of this year to a record low and
each month since it's fallen
in a consumer-led economy like ours that
is bad news bad news as well for the the
shops and the stores behind me here on
the high street in reading not only do
they have to contend with those
falling overall numbers of retail sales
and the consumer confidence what they
have got impending uh not just the bank
of england's recession but
as part of that
the price cap in this autumn for energy
it doesn't apply to them remember they
won't have that they will have to
potentially negotiate their own energy
prices and that for some of them will be
catastrophic
indeed
difficult times for them adele thanks
very much indeed
let's take a look now at some of those
other headlines and a man has been
charged with the murder of 87 year old
pensioner thomas o'halloran who was
stabbed to death on his mobility scooter
earlier this week
lee beyer will appear at wilson
magistrates court today
it's been revealed that a security flaw
could allow hackers to take control of
apple iphones ipads macs and even some
ipod models the tech giant admits the
issue may have been actively exploited
it's put a software update and is urging
people to install it straight away
health leaders say the uk is facing a
humanitarian crisis of worsening health
outcomes unless the government does more
to help with rising energy costs nhs
confederation has written a letter to
ministers saying surging prices mean
that people will have to choose between
skipping meals to heat their homes or
living in poor conditions
the man accused of trying to kill salman
rushdie has been denied bail during his
latest court appearance in new york
state hadi matar has been indicted on
charges that he stabbed the author at a
lecture event last week leaving him
severely wounded mata has pleaded not
guilty to attempted murder and assault
a judge in the united states says he's
willing to publish part of the warrant
which was used by the fbi to search the
home of former president donald trump in
hearing last night prosecutors were
given a week to submit a copy of the
affidavit with proposed redactions for
the information they want to keep secret
the new zealand family has found the
bodies of two children in suitcases they
bought at a storage unit auction
police believe that the remains of the
children aged between 5 and 10 had been
hidden for several years
now ukraine and russia are again trading
accusations as to who's responsible for
shelling near europe's largest nuclear
power station an increasingly alarmed un
wants to demilitarize the area around
the zaparica plant but russia has
rejected that proposal
well this video posted on social media
yesterday appears to show russian
military vehicles inside the nuclear
plant ukrainian engineers are still
operating the plant despite the russian
occupation the skies alice the bunkel is
in the southern ukrainian city of odessa
for us this morning and alastair there's
clearly deep concern around this nuclear
plant and it's growing
yeah real concern particularly today uh
because russia has suggested that
ukraine might be planning uh provocation
some form of attack uh ukraine though
says that it has intelligence
that russia is going to do the same at
the power plant and then blame the
ukrainians and our colleagues over at
nbc news have been reporting sources
that say that some of the workers at the
plant are being given an impromptu
day off today which obviously is rather
an ominous sign so it is becoming the
attention at the moment of the world to
making sure that
an incident is occurring at the power
plant and there is no major radioactive
leak as as could happen if fighting
continues around it that was what the
u.n secretary general antonio guterres
discussed with the turkish president and
ukrainian president uh when they met in
the west of ukraine yesterday uh any
attempts to try and make the zaparisia
power plant into a demilitarized zone
have been rejected and there doesn't
seem to be any progress either
in getting independent inspectors in so
it is something of a stalemate at the
moment uh with urgency increasing uh
elsewhere as well there were reports
overnight that an air base in the west
of crimea uh was attacked and a number
of explosions there and there were also
reports as yet
that the bridge over the curt strait
built by russia after they annexed
crimea in 2014 which connects crimea
with mainland russia where there is a
number of drones flying above it an
anti-aircraft fire engaged those so
quite a lot of activity again on the
crimean peninsula today the u.n
secretary general will come here to
odessa uh to visit the
one of the rare probably the only really
it's fair to say diplomatic success that
has come out of this six month war is
that deal between the russians and
ukrainians to allow grain to leave these
ports he will come down here to look at
that to try and make sure that that deal
continues and the shipments are allowed
in and out but i think his thoughts and
the thoughts of
the world will be on what is happening
at the zappos nuclear power plant indeed
and we'll watch those events very
closely today alastair thanks very much
indeed
to say with us coming up on sky news
breakfast a year after the taliban took
control of afghanistan we're going to
hear from two people who fled the
country
[Music]
welcome back let's get more now on our
top story here this morning the
continuing disruption to public
transport as workers in london strike
again today well speaking to the program
this morning the transport secretary
grant shaps accused transport unions of
prolonging the dispute that's led to
nationwide strikes by not putting
potential deals to their members i asked
him if the government is shirking its
responsibilities to end the worsening
standoff
well the people who have to be around
the table are the employers and uh the
workers representatives in this case the
the unions um they're the only people
who can settle the strike uh of course
government sets the mandate overall uh
because we have the further wider
responsibility for not just how much
real workers are paid but how much uh
care workers are paid how much staff in
the nhs doctors and nurses and police
and so many other public services so of
course we have to set an overall
framework the treasury has has done that
in a way as i say
rail is fortunate there is so much
modernization required for work
practices which have no place in the
21st century
at all i'll give you a good example of
this is um there are the same number of
ticket offers more or less than there
were when virtually all the tickets were
sold at ticket offices we want to get
people out from behind the glass and
onto the stations helping helping
customers
sorry to interrupt you but you're saying
this has got nothing to do with the
government there's nothing you can do
there's nothing you can do to move this
on
and that's not what i'm saying i'm
saying the government has to set the
overall mandate the framework but the
technical discussions have to take place
between the employers and the unions and
they have been and that's why we've got
offers of eight percent over two years
on the table with uh as i said it varies
depending on which part of the the which
union and which part of the railway
we're talking about but no compulsory
redundancies for example with the
network rail maintenance side uh and
much more
if the unions won't put the offer to
their members i'm afraid we will have to
impose some of these solutions and
that's where we're moving to now
well it's time to say good morning to
our political correspondent amanda acas
hello to you uh so grant shap's there no
real sign of the government certainly
giving any ground on this absolutely
quite bullish language once again from
grant chaps on this almost a kind of
divide and rules suggesting that the
union barons need to get out of the way
of the prospect of a deal being reached
with the membership over this offer of
around 8
pay increase now of course as we were
hearing from mick lynch yesterday um the
unions believe that that would be in
real terms a pay cut we know inflation
is standing at 10.1 percent they clearly
believe they need to fight for their
rights of their members indeed the whole
principle of collective responsibility
and collective bargaining rather from
the unions is that that is their right
to be able to do so and indeed i think
the sense that the government might
start imposing some of these modernizing
practices that are part of these
negotiations is also something will
probably inflame tensions now the
conservative party the government
clearly believe that this is their
responsibility they say they're standing
up for you know for working people
clearly believe that this will go down
well with voters but i think across the
country everyone understands the impact
of the cost of living crisis
everyone is looking at how far their
wages will go with concerns about energy
bills rising um and so perhaps as we
were hearing from the unions yesterday
we could see a much broader range of
industrial action with many more workers
in other sectors continuing to call for
the same thing so i think they are on
fairly shaky ground on this particularly
this morning we're hearing yet more
bleak economic indicators a sense that
consumer um consumer confidence is its
lowest level since record began in the
1990 in the 1970s
we know inflation is continuing to rise
labor this is grist to their mail really
as the kind of conservative leadership
candidates continue to argue about the
best way of dealing with this they're
today calling for parliament to be
recalled in order to discuss their plan
to freeze the energy price count because
we know at the end of this month it's
likely to go up we're expecting it to
rise to three and a half thousand pounds
currently it's just two thousand pounds
neighbors say mps need to discuss what
to do about this and at the moment the
government don't appear to be taking um
that on board yeah indeed and we'll be
talking to labour very shortly actually
amanda thanks very much indeed
now families and survivors of online
child sexual abuse have written an open
letter to rishi sunak and liz truss
asking them to promise to pass the
delayed online safety bill the bill was
due to make its way through parliament
before recess but has been delayed until
new prime minister is in place sky's
aisha zaheed reports
danielle was just 14 when an online
children's game led to abuse she was
targeted by a man who claimed to be 16
but was in fact in his late forties
he used a chat room feature to groom
danielle before arranging to meet her
and sexually assaulting her
he arranged to meet me after school
um
i got into his car and discovered that
he was a lot older than what he was so i
just froze
from that point he took me to a forest
and that's when the sexual abuse started
um and that escalated
as he threatened if he spoke out or told
anybody about it he'd fit in my family
so i felt like i had to
i had to see him again
after the third occasions that got a lot
more violent
danielle's story is part of a bigger
problem in the last decade online child
sexual abuse cases increased tenfold
according to the nspcc the proposed
online safety bill aims to help tackle
the issue and address wider problems by
regulating how online platforms protect
users from harmful content but with the
legislation delayed until a new prime
minister is in place survivors and
campaigners have written an open letter
to both candidates urging liz trust and
rishi sunak to resist calls to water
down the bill and commit to delivering
it without any more delay
that every
month that the online safety bill is not
passed we can expect to see another 3
500 online child sexual abuse offences
recorded by police forces in the uk
but on top of that if the bill is
delayed we will
lose what is to be a really crucial
pillar of the the fight against online
sexual child abuse
the message they're sending is clear
by coming together and speaking out
we want the next prime minister to know
that what happened to us
was avoidable
and it's now in their hands
to protect our children and to make sure
there is safety measures in place for
children like using the the internet now
the online safety bill has been years in
the making people like danielle have
spent even longer raising awareness
change can't come soon enough aisha
zahid sky news
now this week marks one year since the
taliban took control of afghanistan
following their return to power many
afghans have had to flee the country
fearing for their safety among them is
aisha kuram a women's rights activist
who left her university studies to
escape the country in the weeks after
the taliban took control and i'm very
pleased to say that aisha joins me now
from berlin um thanks very much indeed
for talking to us
tell us a little bit about what that was
like a lot of young people
live in afghanistan it's got one of the
highest proportions of young people in
the world so what was it like what's it
like to live under the taliban as a
young person there
well thank you very much for having me
um
well actually
i was
um
i was born as a refugee
two years before the line of 9 11 and i
returned uh back to my homeland when it
was
emerging back from the rebels of war and
also the repressive regime of taliban
and after 2001 i was fortunate enough to
go to school
and i was able to continue my higher
education and be enrolled in one of the
biggest public universities in
afghanistan
and study political science um
and
today after 22 years
of all the progress of all the
transformation that we have witnessed in
the country we are back to the ground
zero we are back to the point we have
started from
and
the day when
i received the call not to leave home
from
to university
it was the day when the taliban took
over and that was exactly the day when a
lot of university professors they have
said
specifically goodbye to female students
and
and it
it was
one of the saddest and
the most shocking and the most
shattering moments of of my whole life
and
um
the fact that taliban were taking over
the country um and at the same time
seeing how
um
the
international community and and our own
republic government
they have betrayed the people of
afghanistan
um
it it changed the life of the younger
generation for divorce and
today families are turn apart and
people staying back in afghanism
they are either
trying to choose between
migrating um migration or starvation and
there is no choice in between for them
and very briefly what hope do you have
for the future afghanistan
well actually since i came
to germany
and when i got involved in activities
to help my people back home
um when i've tried to
continue my activism
i've
since we are providing health care
services for when children in
afghanistan i have seen in the past few
months thousands of children
dying in front of us who wouldn't have
died last year this time for the reasons
that were so easily avoidable
and today
um
with a whole state of statelessness with
the country being on the brink of
starvation and with the insecurities
rising in the oppression of taliban
choking
the afghan nation
i think the most important thing for for
the for us and at least at the
international level would be to change
the narrative afghanistan is not a
failed
nation it the political failure is an
undeniable reality but
the afghan youth are not
not not failed and if there is any force
that can stand um against oppression and
that could be a force for justice and
democracy in afghanistan that is the
afghan youth and they are not failed
today
okay we must leave it there but aisha
kurum a real pleasure to talk to you
this morning thanks very much indeed for
your time
thank you for having me well let's stay
with the situation in afghanistan i'm
joined by muhammad hakmal a former chief
of public health in afghanistan who had
to flee taliban rule a very good morning
to you perhaps we should start with why
you had to flee tell us
what happened to you i know it's very it
might be difficult for you but as much
as you're you're happy to talk about
well thank you very much uh gents for
having me i when the
i i left like many other icons because
of this conflict in the country and
because many people also specifically
those that they were in a senior
position they were targeted and i was
one of one of them you know so because
of
several limitations you know several
challenges i left the country i know
leaving the country is not an easy
decision for anyone
but sometimes you know when it comes
between life and death you know so you
need to select you know one of the
options that at least you can survive
well yes and i know that you had a very
difficult time at the hands of the
taliban but but let's talk about the
work that you were doing in afghanistan
and and how frustrating it is for you to
not be able to continue that now
well
as
my other friends fellow afghans you know
aisha mentioned so today's situation in
afghanistan is really painful because we
are seeing people they are dying from
the preventable cause from some very
simple you know measures that these
people life could be also safe and
unfortunately when we are also looking
to the international commitments you
know community commitments so what they
are saying they are not putting in
action
so with the
conflict you know that we are also
seeing in ukraine afghanistan is not
unfortunately in the headlines it's not
because the situation has been improved
because afghanistan is politically i
think not in the
location that should be also discussed
in the media and
we are also seeing people also they
seeing people that they are not being
able you know to apply for the
scholarship to get education abroad you
know so afghan youth also has been
unfortunately these days also deprived
of the education not only inside the
country but outside the country as well
let me give one example of uk uk
government has also funding you know
this tuning scholarship and
unfortunately our people this year so
the young generations they will not be
able you know to apply for the
scholarship it's not only your case in
several other government so they were
providing educational opportunity during
the last two decades but these days
because of the crisis and it's not only
you know limitation inside the country
it's outside the country we are also
been deprived you know from most of the
opportunity
yeah well mohammed hakmal we appreciate
you talking to us this morning and
telling us about your experience thanks
very much indeed
my pleasure
now labor is calling for parliament to
be recalled on monday to urgently
discuss the cost of living crisis the
shadow leader of the house of commons
fangum debonair has written to the prime
minister boris johnson and the two
candidates who are vying to replace him
and i'm very pleased to say that she
joins me now a very good morning to you
so you've proposed your energy price
plan you now want parliament recalled
but we have in the past weeks heard from
the liberal democrats the snp and gordon
brown
wanting parliament to be recalled are
you a bit late to this
no i mean i think the most important
thing is that households are worrying
now and because the off-gem um price
rise is due to be announced in seven
days time um the government has failed
to come up with their own plan and we
announced our plan which is now fully
you know it's fully costed we know where
we're going to get the money we're going
to take the money from those big oil and
gas producers who have so benefited from
the windfall in oil and gas prices and
we need to get back to parliament on
monday so that we can legislate before
the off-gem price rise the time to act
is now the government has failed they
could have acted weeks ago they could
have acted months ago in fact when
labour first called for a winful tax on
oil and gas way back in january
that is why under our plan we would back
date that windfall tax and close the
loophole that the government put in the
energy price levy we would backdate it
all the way back to january because
nobody can say that we haven't worn the
oil and gas companies that their massive
profits at a time of national crisis
with inflation skyrocketing skyrocketing
have to be used to help households
through this very difficult time
but what would a debate achieve when
we're just two weeks away from having a
new prime minister announced and they
will have a plan of their own
what it would achieve would it be to
pass a law it wouldn't be just so that
we could discuss it it would be so that
we can pass the legislation that would
be necessary for us to override the
price rise uh the rise in the price cap
that off gem will be announcing in seven
days time that could happen next week if
we get back to parliament on monday that
is up to the government to request the
speaker and they can do that the prime
minister is perfectly capable of opening
his email which i sent to him last night
asking him to do just this i've also
asked both leadership candidates to back
that call if they're really serious
about helping working people and
struggling households and businesses
through this crisis through this cost of
living crisis they should back our call
right now and we should be passing that
legislation next week well yes and
obviously you think it's the best plan
but not everybody else does there are a
lot of people out there that say it's
very expensive and it's only a
short-term fix as soon as you
release that
freeze on price cap inflation will just
shoot up again
well what we're focusing on is what's
going to help people right now and we do
know where we're going to get the money
for that plan and as i said we are going
to concentrate primarily on getting the
money back from the oil and gas
producers who are making massive win for
profits and have been for some time now
that's how we'd pay for it it would help
those people for example those four
million households who are on
pre-payment meters where they have to
feed a meter with cash um and top it up
at the local shop if they run out and
i've watched this happen in struggling
working families who have been put on a
prepayment meter and they run out of
power because that power costs much more
than it does for those people on bills
and direct debits now we would fix that
gap with our plan and we would also keep
the price cap from rising so that would
save most households around a thousand
pounds now yes we'll need a long-term
plan as well labor does have a long-term
plan and i would like us to get into
government sooner rather than later so
we can insulate homes invest in
renewable energy protect our energy
security and conduct that green energy
sprint that this country and our planet
so badly needs but right now we have to
focus on what's in front of people right
now and their worries for how they're
going to get through the winter whether
or not they're going to be able to
afford to heat and eat and that's the
start choice we're facing and the
government needs to do the right thing
get us back to parliament and legislate
him
we're in the midst of uh rail strikes
once again are you happy with kirsten's
stance on this discouraging
members from going to the picket lines
does that is are you on the side of
working people in labour anymore
of course we're on the side of working
people labor believes in the right to
strike and we also know that
constituency mps should and do always
listen to the needs and views of our
constituents and we do my job as a
member of kier's shadow cabinet is to
prepare to get us into government so
that we can pass in the first hundred
days that employment bill that workers
rights chartered that would so benefit
people who are right now calling out for
help and understandably so that's our
role in the labour movement that
employment bill is something that angela
rainer has worked on with the trade
unions and it would protect the right to
bargain and protect the right to fair
pay it would end the unfair practices of
foreign damaging people's lives very
briefly you're about to fall off air
would you go on a picket line or not
that's not my role my role is actually
to listen to my constituents and to work
on the legislation that would help
prevent the need for strikes to take
place in the first place